So now you've seen that even if we
can observe a pattern between two variables, we always
have to consider lurking variables. Referring back to
our sleep data we see that there's a relationship
between hours slept and temporal memory but we
can't necessarily be confident that sleep causes better memory.
What if we wanted to prove that sleep
causes better memory? Well, if we want to show relationships
only as with scatter plots, we can
do observational studies where we just take note
of already existing data or we can do
surveys where people are the main subjects and
we ask them questions that we're interested in knowing the answers to. But if we
want to show causation that one particular variable causes
another then we'd have to a controlled experiment.
Throughout this course, you'll see a lot of examples of
controlled experiments. And we're also going to ask you a
lot of survey questions and then we can analyze the
data you give us. Let's take a closer look at surveys